[Inaudible].
Hey, wisecrack, Jared here.
It's with a heavy heart that I tell you all that I'll be stepping down from
wisecrack. At the end of September, it's been an amazing journey.
I have learned so much during these past eight years because of all the great
teachers, artists, experts I've collaborated with over the years,
I've become a much more thoughtful,
compassionate and inquisitive person building wisecrack from scratch with my
co-founder. Jacob has been the most rewarding experience of my life thus far,
Jacob and I met in college and moved to Hollywood with the dream of making
movies together and ended up kind of falling into the YouTube game.
[Inaudible].
Other than movies, one thing we were both passionate about was education.
And if one could think of our business partnership as a marriage,
then wisecrack was our baby.
It was an exhausting experience of high highs and low lows,
but it was because of wisecrack that I was able to eventually quit my soul
crushing job of editing corporate videos for a living.
I will always be so grateful to the fans for allowing that to happen.
I'm not leaving because of any juicy drama like Takeshi kind of sheroes
character set in the Chungking express.
Everything has an expiration date even love, but you all need not worry.
I'm leaving the channel in the incredibly capable hands of my right hand,
Alec who has helped me shape and edit over 300 videos over the past four years.
The future is a little uncertain for me,
but I have to remember that's part of what makes life exciting, right?
If you guys want to keep up with what I'm up to,
you can follow me on Instagram at father of Woody,
but it's mostly just pictures of my dog. I want to thank all the writers,
researchers, designers, motion graphics, artists, teachers, eight bit animators,
illustrators, cinematographers, sound, engineers, production assistants,
makeup artists, actors, hosts, directors, editors, podcasters,
and producers that have helped on the project over the years. Honestly,
there are so many of you. This would have turned into a much longer video.
I tried to name you all, but you all know who you are and I love you all dearly,
but most of all, I want to thank you. The fans for sticking with us without you,
we would have never made it this far, especially our patrons. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you for all your support.
It means the world to me and as always, thanks for watching guys. Peace.
What is happening at an hour of.